[Music]
and that day
has come ariana grande is officially a
married woman
now e.t is learning how her family feels
about it
on monday et confirmed that the singer
tied the knot with luxury real estate
agent
dalton gomez over the weekend a source
reveals they got hitched in montecito
california
and the wedding was extremely small and
intimate with only their closest family
and friends
as for ari's mom joan and older brother
frankie
the source says they're over the moon
happy for her
quote they think dalton really balances
ariana out and allows her to be her true
self
and it sounds like ari agrees the source
adds
ariana appreciates that dalton accepts
her and loves her for who she is
he's a little nerdy and hardworking and
she loves that about him
he's also very protective over her and
goes above and beyond to make her happy
i'm happy life is good the 27 year old
seven ring singer got engaged to gomez
in december
after nine months of dating at the time
ari posted a pic
on instagram of her unique diamond and
pearl engagement ring
and while she never confirmed the
backstory on the bling
many fans think the pearl is the same
one seen in this photo she posted in
2014
a gift her grandmother gave her
featuring a pearl that was part of a tie
pin that belonged to her late
grandfather
i feel your love every day and while the
couple keeps their relationship
pretty private we have seen a few
glimpses into their lives
like the time dalton helped ari quite
literally
make it rain it'll be raining all summer
but we'll surely be dancing as it does
cheers to a lifetime of dancing and
laughing together
as mr and mrs gomez